this video was supported in part by our
friends at Monday comm find out how it
can boost your team after this video
this is what if and here's what would
happen if there was no friction for one
minute friction is what allows us to
move and to slow down friction is how we
pick things up and hold onto them to be
totally honest there isn't much we could
do without friction a world without
friction would be unlivable but do you
think you could function for one minute
without it the reason why friction is so
important to our world is because it
affects everything that's in motion when
any object is moving slipping or sliding
in one direction friction is acting in
the opposite direction so for example
consider something as simple as walking
your feet are pushing backward against
the ground and the ground reacts by
pushing forward on your foot allowing
you to accelerate but it's a lot easier
to walk on concrete than it is to walk
on ice right that's because ice has a
much lower coefficient of friction than
concrete
in other words ice is much smoother than
concrete so it has less resistance
causing your feet to slip and slide this
same example can be applied to vehicles
in fact car tires are designed with
friction in mind to optimize your safety
and to make sure that you can turn and
stop without skidding in dry conditions
having a tire that's completely smooth
actually gives you better handling since
there's more surface area to generate
frictional forces but the reason why
your car's tires probably have treads is
to improve traction in wet conditions
when you're driving in rain or snow even
a thin layer of water between the road
and your tire can cause you to lose
control that's because there's less
contact between the tire and the road so
the forces of friction can't work their
magic but tires with treads have grooves
that divert the excess water so the
rubber can connect with the road and you
can drive safely of course there are
plenty of other ways to test how
friction works do some redecorating play
a game of ice hockey or light a match
fire works for friction yeah
celebrate friction and be grateful it
exists because you don't know what
you've got until it's gone for one
minute cut the fireworks matches don't
work anymore and you can't use lighters
in fact you can't pick anything up
because your ability to grip and pick
things up is due to friction anything
you were holding on to the moment
friction cease to exist would instantly
fall to the ground or fly out of your
hand if you were walking when friction
disappeared your legs would still work
but you wouldn't go anywhere but if you
were in a moving vehicle you'd keep
going going and going and going
until you crashed into something your
brakes are friction in fact for that one
seemingly endless minute of chaos and
destruction terminal velocity would
cease to exist meaning that anything in
motion would be a deadly projectile at
least it wouldn't get ropeburn but that
tree that penny that runaway train is
actually the least of your worries
because within just one minute of losing
friction actually within an instant of
losing friction the whole world would
just become one big formless featureless
blob considering that everything on
earth is composed of atoms and particles
and that all atoms and particles are
held together by friction well what do
you think you get when you take away
friction nothing you lose everything
instantly so if you've ever wondered why
skidding cars and baseball slides look
so cool well just be grateful for
friction
yeah it can make life hard sometimes but
it beats losing literally everything on
this planet so go on try it for yourself
take a walk and feel the friction
between your feet in the ground but you
know there's good friction and then
there's awkward friction like at the
workplace with Monday calm you and your
team will always be on the same page
this intuitive team management tool
boasts productivity and collaboration
making every user feel empowered and
part of something bigger than their own
individual tasks head on over to their
website right now and sign up for a free
trial but don't go too far
double back quickly for another episode
of what if